another one of the books that we read
for class was poor economics co-written
by Professor Banerjee from MIT and one
of the things that he discusses is micro
lending and how the international
development community has changed their
respective of micro lending in the past
ten years ten years ago it was sort of
seen as the Silver Bullet for
international development and today
we're seeing more problems with it and
not really seeing it as much of a tool
for poverty alleviation perhaps
consumption transformation but not
necessarily poverty alleviation and I
wonder what do you think about this
change is micro lending still going to
be the future of impact investing in
impact investment or is it on the way
out right many many as she's packed in
there let me take your loss statement
first and I think that it is fair to say
that microfinance generally let's use it
as a generic term was one of the first
areas or sub sectors if you will that
caught the attention of the both
commercial investment community and also
perhaps the philanthropic community
foundations alongside multilaterals as
this silver bullet as you as you put it
so we're impact investing is concerned
it's it sort of been there and been
around the block I would I would point
to to sort of seminal moments within
that one was was what Muhammad Yunus did
and the other was a very big transaction
where ABN AMRO Bank of Holland bought
bank or L in Brazil specifically to get
access to their micro finance portfolio
so that was huge that was the first
move by commercial bank that was saying
to the market this can be highly
profitable I think that you need to
unpack what microfinance is or has
become and I think again underlying that
criticism one has to draw a very
important distinction between explicitly
consumer finance orientated institutions
that are providing small loans small
amounts of capital or credit and others
that are doing very different types of
microfinance or in some cases both
there's payroll based lending there's
group lending there are very there are
many many models and one can debate the
the impact that any given model has but
I think that one has to look at those
you know separately from from from
financial institutions that are
providing you alone for example to buy a
television or to buy a white good and
that is a debate that we could have as
to whether or not that's that's you know
a good thing or a bad thing but it is
different so I'm nervous about lumping
at all in one